hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on Monster on our world
again for a third video today but today
we're gonna be talking about this quest
that came up during the spring blossom
event obviously every single event quest
is now back in session so I wanted to
recap one of the very important quest
throughout this event that you should
definitely be doing this event quest in
specific is the snow in cherry blossoms
I believe it's star 9 I don't remember
the HR for it but it's either 13 29 or
50 I'm pretty sure you have to be higher
than 13 I'm not entirely sure but I do
know that is a star 9 quest like I said
this is an old quest so if you already
know about this you already know what
you're doing
but just the case people who aren't
aware this mission has you fight a
tempered lejiana and Ratheon and you
basically have to just beat the [ __ ] out
of them once you defeat them you will
get lots of HR at the end quick tip
lejiana is weak to thunder and fire
while rathian is weak to dragon and
thunder so if you have any of those
weapons in your arsenal definitely use
those after you're done with the mission
just queue up with by either by yourself
or with the team I happen to do a team
in the gameplay and we swooped and
killed the moon with maybe about 5
minutes continuously repeat this quest
to get tons of HR mine filled up almost
my entire HR meter and this thing is
going to be going on until the 19th of
April at the end of the events you'll
have tons of time to grind and gain XP
and get that really hime hunter ink and
that's about it it's really short really
sweet and it gives you a lots of HR
especially if you know what you're doing
I managed to clear in about 10 to 15
minutes solo but with the team and that
we knew what we were doing I cleared it
in about 5 minutes
that's going to be the end of the video
today guys I'm gonna show the rest of
the gameplay in the background with some
lo-fi hip-hop music because I always
love that type of music it's real chill
vibes either way like I said it's going
to be the end like the video if you did
enjoy subscribe if you're new I got a
lot of Monster Hunter guides up and
coming and stuff like that and my old
solo guides for all the old monsters if
you're having trouble with that I have
the ignition great sword as well as to
get the new Pookie B outfit that's
coming with the spring blossom event and
there's also supposed to be a Megaman
outfit for your pal ergo coming next
week or so I'm not entirely sure if
that's ps4 only but if it's not ps4 only
I will gladly do that video for you
because I'm on the Xbox then we have
that Devil May Cry collaboration
whenever that happens to release
whenever it does I will gladly do a
video on that my two most recent videos
are going to be at the end of this
if you guys do want to check that out
and with that guys hope you have a great
rest your day and draw the rest of the
gameplay have fun with the event in
peace out
[Music]
you
[Music]